hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game you guys requested from the
world Rapids Team Championship with his
former World classical Champion Vladimir
kramnik versus bukash and even though uh
kramnik no longer plays classical chess
he's officially retired he still comes
out of um retirement and maybe for uh
for Rapid tournament or a blitz
tournament or he even plays those um uh
no castling uh games in uh sometimes uh
in Dortmund I believe uh but now this is
a very serious game as it's a former
world champion against gukesh who is
currently number eight in the world on
the uh classical ratings list so it's
gonna be uh very good game I hope you
guys enjoy it let's check it out and see
if uh Vladimir can still wield them
pieces uh so uh Vladimir has the white
pieces and he opens with Ponte for
gookish opens uh with Pawn to C5 he goes
for the Sicilian Defense neither three
E6 and now Pawn to D4 uh striking in the
center and uh karmic even said that he
they weren't sure if they were gonna
even play here if they should form a
team but they did it and they enrolled
only retired or almost retired players
like himself then swedler is playing
okay they also have a Dominguez on board
one who is a very very much active but
they are you know here to to have some
fun whereas gukesh he is in a very very
strong team he's in a team with um I
would live on with carwana and I don't
want to trick you guys so I'm just gonna
check real quickly uh who are all the
players yeah I guess car one on board
one level one on board two Bookers board
three and then uh feeling and that's
Australia on board four and five in the
Schneider on board six as uh this is a
sort of a tournament where you have on
board six you have an unrated player
someone who is not a professional player
so it's it's a fun event but okay uh we
have found the D4 C capture Sunday for
Knight captures and now Knight to C6 we
have Knight to C3 and queen to C7 going
for the basketball variation of the
taimano with Bishop to E3 and pawn to A6
but E2 we have Knight to F6 and now
castles in Bishop to E7 so this has all
been played before nothing new here on
the F4 and by chronic we have won the D6
and now Pawn to A4 so of course Google's
team is much much stronger in raiding
and of course are the favorites so in
this end of course Vladimir being the
former world champion and having the
white pieces he feels that well he feels
an obligation to play for the win with
the white pieces something he said in an
interview after the game
uh we have Castles by Gucci H1 and now
uh the usual move here is Rook d8 it's
pretty much a tough move here no one
plays anything else it's the considered
the best but here gookers plays Knight
captures on D4 he uh wants to throw uh
kramnik out of his comfort zone maybe he
doesn't know this line as it's not very
good and if he didn't check it with the
computer maybe he doesn't know how to
punish it but uh you know Lucas could
not be more wrong with Queen captures on
D4 Bishop to D7 preparing Bishop to C6
and now Pawn to A5 grabbing more space
here on the queen side with Bishop to C6
and now Bishop to F3 uh defending on e4
and also ready to counter this uh Bishop
if the Center opens up we have Rook uh
Rook 8 to C8 and now he goes back with
the queen queen to D2 We have Queen to
B8 Now The Rook nicely controls the C
file and Rook F the D1 and here there is
a game where Rook F to D it was played
but here we have Knights the D7 by
gookish and it is now already as of move
16 that we have a completely new game so
what does that letting me want to do he
wants to go after the Bushman C6 he goes
92 he wants to go Knight to D4 and
capture the bishop here if possible we
have rook f38 and now Knights the D4 and
now glucose just returns with Knight to
F6 uh we have Knight captures on C6 uh
Vladimir now grabs the bishop pair B
captures and now Bishop to B6 uh forces
The Rook to move away Rook to E8 and now
Queen to E2 here Kramden goes after the
A6 pawn and while you could expect
something like Queen to B7 to be played
uh uh decides the strike in the center
he plays Pawn to D5 and okay you can't
really capture on A6 right away because
then just D captures an E4 attacks the
bishop and creates a past Pawn so he
captures on D5 we have C captures on D5
and now Queen captures on A6 with real
characters on C2 so Vladimir gets his
best a pawn but gookish gets his passed
deep Pawn but also here kramnik has the
past B Pawn he's unable to push it to B4
right away as the bishop covers that so
he has to prepare it first he plays
Queen to B5 this prepares B4 but also
makes room for the a pawn to start
marching forward with Queen captures on
F4 bukish even grabs a pawn for this and
now Pawn to A6 so very very nicely
played by kramnik Rook to A8 to gookish
has to be ready for that pawn and now a
beautiful move by cramlington Bishop to
G1 the absolute top engine move just
going back uh freeing up the queen so a
A7 and queen to be it can be played not
for the moment as the queen here still
guards the B8 square but not but also
the bishop here covers the H2 Pawn you
know the gookers will put a bishop on D6
and try and Checkmate chronic on H2 so
Bishop to D6 and now Rook to A4 uh uh
activating The Rook a little bit more
attacking the queen so it comes with
tempo uh Rook to D4 is also an idea you
could also play that uh Queen to E5
still keeping the pressure Here and Now
Pawn to A7 and this Pawn to A7 is a very
interesting move by coming because uh
well how do you decide to do keep the B
Pawn because your B Pawn is hanging you
play B3 and then allow something like H5
we can even show a nice line here let's
say a V3 H5 and if A7 now you play
Knights to G4 and all right it's very
annoying just threatening to capture on
H2 so you're gonna have to capture and
now if you don't want to see G3 you have
to capture the pawn but it also means
you will lose your A7 Pawn so
um basically uh if you if you don't
um if you try to defend it then you lose
the the a pawn it's as simple as that so
A7 and giving up the B2 Pawn Win
captures on B2 and now Queen back to F1
of course uh kramni does not want to
trade Queens we have quanta H6 the
bookish creates some breathing room for
his King here and the bishop to D4
attacks the queen attacks the knife here
uh but Queen to B3 attacks the rook and
A4 so Rook to A6 attacks the bishop and
now Bishop to C7 the again an excellent
Square for the bishop and now uh you
can't really go Rook to B1 it's a nice
move but then Queen to C4 would just
offer a queen trade so nothing really
happening there so here kramnik played
Bishop to E2 now the bishop covers the
C4 square and now he's ready to maybe
play Rook to B1 but Lucas now plays
Knight to E4 and this is a very very
annoying move uh as it uh well let's
play Rook to B1 already Knight to G3
check just ends the game there's no way
to to avoid sfh captures and G3 Queen
captures and G3 threatening Checkmate
and there's nothing you can do if if you
go King to G1 just Queen to H2 with
checking to F2 Queen to H4 with check
King to E3 and now Queen to G3 with
check uh whatever you play let's say
block with the bishop Bishop to F3 Queen
to G5 would check and now of course
after King to D3 you will play Queen to
D to check mate so that is not possible
so instead after Knight E4 Bishop to H5
was played
uh comedy Now goes after Queen captures
on F7 uh and now comes Pawn to F6 Here
pawn to G6 was very much winning for
gukesh the point is a very funny one uh
because after the bishop moves you will
play Knight at the D2 attack the queen
and the bishop here and once the queen
moves doesn't really matter where you're
just gonna trade everything captures
captures captures captures and look at
this the H2 Pawn is hanging as the
bishop here also attacks it uh Rook
captures some H2 King to G1 Rook C2 and
now you have a winning position of
course yes the the A7 Pawn is very nice
but I mean you're up three pawns so
completely winning of course but okay
after Bishop page five uh Vladimir
managed to trigger cash Bookers play
spawn to F6 and now uh we have and now
we have uh uh Rook captures on E6 which
is not the way to go here you should
play Bishop to G4 go after these six
pawn and once the pawn attacks it now
you go Bishop to F3 and now if Knight to
D2 now it's a little bit different it's
not the exact same that we've shown
because Queen E1 goes after the E6 pawn
and if you insist on this then Queen
captures an E6 check and now you get
checkmated horribly King date Queen
captures an H6 with check the g-pawn
cannot move King to G8 and now Queen to
G7 with Checkmate so after Pawn to F6 we
have Rook captures on E6 and now gookish
is completely winning and I'm sure you
guys already know what move he played
it's the same line that we've already
shown uh of course you see it without
even pausing the video it is night the
G3 check
now or of course you have the capture if
you play King to G1 then you lose your
queen so H captures in G3 Queen capture
is now threatening Checkmate and King
the G1 doesn't work we already uh have
shown how it loses terribly so Bishop to
E5 attacks the bishop here and the queen
stop in Queen to HD Checkmate Bishop
counters and E5 you have to give back
the piece Rook captures and now uh Queen
not F characters of course you don't
want to allow Bishop to F7 check so
Queen captures on E5 and now Bishop to
G6 uh not just getting the bishop out of
Harm's Way but also keeping the black
king uh stuck there on G8 and also comes
with Tempo The Rock here is attacked so
Rook to C4 and now Queen to F2 and here
again a very interesting position Queen
to G5 by Gucci he didn't spot that the
A7 Pawn is actually free uh we're gonna
I'm gonna show it because the point is
after Queen captures an A7 there is a
rook the H4 with check and now King to
G1 Queen to checking the F1 Rook Dev for
check and not just a very nice King Khan
King T1 Queen to G3 with tracking to D2
Queen capture sanjitu with check King to
C1 and now Rook the C4 check King to B1
Rook to B for check and with Queen to B
to Checkmate on the next move regardless
of what white plays
uh so after this King the d2 move uh we
have Bishop uh sorry Queen sorry after
this queen to F2 move uh Queen to G5 was
played and now comes Bishop to F5 and
here uh of course the position is now
completely lost but they were both in
time trouble Goku didn't even see that
uh Queen to H5 check picks up the free
rook and D1 so he played Queen to H4
with check he forced the queen trade and
he goes into the end game Queen captures
on H4 Rook captures an H4 with check
King to G1 and now finally he grabs the
pawn Rook captures an A7 Rook captures
on D5 and now King to F7 and he was in
this position on move 43 that Vladimir
kramnik resigned in the game as there is
nothing more to be done here now uh
chronic had an excellent event he won a
lot of games he drew some of them but
this is the only game that he lost now
if you if for those before maybe new to
chess are wondering how to win this it's
actually not that difficult Europe and
exchange and you're up to pawn so that's
quite a lot to give an example if white
tries to go up the board you're going to
play Rook to B4 and now you're ready for
some Rook A3 Rook to B1 Rook day one
action and if King to F3 you will play
G6 kick away the bishop you don't want
to start moving your Rooks to allow this
check so let's just kick away the bishop
and now the bishop has to go somewhere
there just isn't a good Square let's say
Bishop to C8 Rook to A3 check King F2
Rook the B to check King to G1 and now
Rook 882 and if you don't want to get
demolished here you will have to play
Bishop to H3 guard the G2 pawn and now
let's say F5 it completely locks the
bishop out of the game uh there's
nothing to play for here
resigned and an excellent win for uh for
young gookish so you've seen uh how
Lucas tried this uh tricky line against
um kramnik where the Knight was uh
traded on D4 uh after this Knight
captures on the formula kramnik gained
an excellent position he got his Bishop
all the way to B6 so that's great but in
the end when it came to you know time
travel When It Was a Race Google showed
why uh he is now uh world number eight
in In classical chess uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it like I
said first link in the description below
is an interview with Vladimir kramnik
after the tournament so you can uh hear
him talk about gookish about pregnant
and about you know youngsters in chess
nowadays and a lot of other interesting
topics done just based in this channel
if you want to do check it out uh so
yeah once again really hope you enjoyed
it I would like to thank Robert Bloom
Andrew woolly mocosoft the grizzly
justfestival.org.gg and India moon for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on you
wonderful suggestions such as this one
and whatever else happens in the Chess
World so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day